so the end of the year is here which
means most people are thinking about
writing out their business plan for 2022
finishing off the year strong there's a
couple things i want you to be thinking
about with business planning one of them
is the phase you are as a business right
now a big mistake many businesses make
that cost them their entire business i
don't want you to be making it i'll make
you aware of that and then number two is
at what point should you go from working
more in your business the day-to-day
stuff versus on your business strategy
planning big thinking when when should
you make that transition we'll talk
about that in today's episode
[Music]
let's get right into it by the end of it
stick around because i'm going to have a
one hour video for you strategy session
if you subscribe to a newsletter and i'm
doing a business planning workshop so i
stick around till then i'll give you the
details on it but let's get right into
it i read this book barbarians to
bureaucrats maybe 10 years ago i
contacted the author i loved the book so
much i contacted him because he wrote
this in the 70s or 80s i think he wrote
it i said i want to buy the rights to
your book he wouldn't sell it to me
because somebody else owns the rights of
the book but this explains pretty much
everything about societies organizations
and countries on what causes a country
or a company to take off and what causes
it to fall and you'll see how this
relates to your business so let's get
right into it in every business okay
every company business there's a profit
a profits the visionary he comes out she
comes out they got energy they're
enthusiastic excitement inspiration one
day we will imagine if one day
that's the vision that's the excitement
we can one day pull this off right so
they attract people and somebody says
man i'm gonna help you go make that
become a reality and that's the
barbarian then barbarians show up
barbarians that are the sobs they're the
ones that take no excuses they are
drivers they're tough to be around
because they're constantly driving
everybody around them sometimes they
drive people out but they're true
believers and the prophet cannot do
anything without the barbarians so think
about this from your business where you
are right now which one of them you are
at the phase you're currently at so then
after the barbarian they're going out
there there's a true believer this
person's no longer by themselves there's
like a flag carrier barbarian maybe he's
not the biggest expert maybe he doesn't
fully know what to do she doesn't know
what to do but they're willing to go do
the work right working 80 hours a week
they're doing their part then they
attract the builder and the explorer
phase the builder and the explorer phase
this is when specialized skill i'm gonna
handle finance i'm gonna handle
technology i'm gonna do ops i'm gonna do
training i'm gonna do web development
i'm gonna do this it's specialized
people start showing up so specialized
skill collaboration people start working
together growth major major recruiting
phase major expansion phase we need to
take this to new york we need to take
this to california we need to take this
to mexico expansion shows up and then
right here is where there's a bit of a
challenge where the administrator shows
up next which you do need the
administrator they come in wanting to
help the administrators wire it slightly
in a different way these guys for the
most part are optimistic that we can do
anything these guys for the most part
are pessimistic or more defense than
offense what if this happens what if we
go out of business there are more what
if the bad things what if we take over
the world but what if we go to so so
it's like it's a very different mindset
right so the administrator system
technology structure transitioning from
offense to defense that's the first
phase where you have but they still have
good intentions
but after the administrator then this
company or this country like america
right now 246 year old whatever the age
is 20 45 year old civilization we've had
success leader of the free world and
then people want to start spending and
bureaucrats show up do they also show up
in the companies okay and here's how
they think
they crucify and they undermine the
profit barbarians and builders and
explorers they can't help themselves
because they're i have the degree do you
know what school i went to do you know
what i did that's the mindset that a lot
of bureaucrats have so they lose
creativity creativity goes away they
brag about what they learned in school
they often convert
others into bureaucratic thinking so
they have a hard time converting these
types of mindsets into their thinking
but they have an easier time converting
them because they're closer to them if
that makes sense so their job is to
convert and undermine they don't even
know they're doing this but they
undermine because they don't like the
fact that the company
admires these guys as much as they do
why do people admire them so much do you
know i got a degree from university of
harvard too you know i want to why are
we respecting those guys i have 10 times
the education they do they kind of come
with that mindset and then they convert
and then they manipulate divide and
flatter they flatter them they convert
them here and sometimes they convert
some of these guys here but they cannot
convert the true believers that are on
this side divide manipulate that's their
expertise we have that on politics today
and a lot of companies have that as well
it shows the aristocrat you know who
aristocrat is aristocrat shows up maybe
it could be
the founder's daughter that accumulated
this wealth and is now like well let me
tell you what we're going to be doing
and they spend all the money right maybe
it's somebody in politics who has never
ran a business before but they want to
go tax everybody spend all the money
because they know what they're doing
with their new policies forget these
rich people who are these guys they
don't know what they're doing we are
going to come and save everybody right
they don't talk to people they don't
shake hands you will rarely see them in
meetings they will go away from talking
to the people and the average guys
because they're too much above that to
go talk to the people prophets these
guys are all about talking to the
day-to-day people because that's how
they build their business
so they inherit the success they've not
earned it
they're distant themselves from
everybody the followers around the
corner and they spend all the money that
these guys work their asses off to
create this this sound familiar to you
right now watch this
if you're in this phase of the business
here you're more working in your
business okay if you're growing a little
bit more you're working more on your
business i'm going to give you what this
role plays but for you with your
business plan you may be watching the
same path i'm only making 58 000 as a
realtor i'd like to go to 200 000 as a
realtor what do i do well you're working
in your business still okay you may be
running a real estate broker shop you
got 22 realtors working for you you're
kind of working still in your business
because maybe you're selling a few homes
per year but you're not starting to work
on your business who do i need to hire
next do i need a ceo do i need a
director of ops do i need to go pay
attention to predictive analytics data
all this stuff what do i need to do with
that right so you're working in versus
on the watch on the inside it's the
day-to-day hiring firing training
selling execution that's the end the
on-site is strategic planning research
and development creating systems
creating different partnerships
collaborating funding you know analytics
all of that stuff that's the on part i
don't know what phase you are but let me
go to the other part about this
if you're at a place where you are here
you better be careful with these guys
when you're hiring people
be very very selective on how much
control you give to who based on what
their motive is watch very very closely
on who you're hiring
if you give too much authority to
somebody that's not going to be a
believer in the whole thing that company
is about to collapse okay if you give
too much and by the way you don't have
to be a 10 billion dollar company to
experience this this can happen at a 10
million dollar real estate shop office
this can happen at a 5 million small
media company shop right and this can
happen at 100 million dollar insurance
company shop this can happen anywhere
you got to pay attention to this stuff
so now
in order for this fall to not come to
your business okay maybe if you're at
this phase good for you but if you're at
this phase if you don't want the fault
to come you have to do whatever you can
to constantly attract and give birth to
synergists now who are synergists they
edify and they build up the prophet they
build up the barbarian and the builder
and the explorer so imagine if you're a
sinner just working at apple this is
what a synergist app would sound like
listen i got to tell you we are the
luckiest people to work at a company
like this that was founded in 1976 i
think that's the year by a 76 or 70. so
microsoft is 76 or 70 some but let's
just say it's apple founded by steve
jobs and steve wozniak these guys had an
idea they were 21 years old they're
playing atari they're making all this
stuff and they had this idea and then
they go and raise the money and then
this person shows up that person shows
up this person shows up and we grew
apple into two trillion dollar company
we would not be here right now without
steve job without steve wozniak without
papa papa papa now if you say this and
all of a sudden in the room you notice a
couple people go like this
you just identify the aristocrat and
bureaucrat because they can't stand that
message okay but that's the synergies
they edify what you want more of you
want more of this that's what they edify
number two they resell the vision apple
was created too
okay think different the 1984 commercial
we don't want to be like ibm we don't
want to be like everybody else we are
different this is what we're doing
that's the message of a synergist right
they're reselling the vision they're
re-reminding they're unifying all the
true believers together who are sitting
there in the meeting who maybe were a
little bit burned out they're like you
know what that's right that's why i
joined this company that's right that's
why i chose to work with you that's what
a sinner just does right his or her
energy indirectly will cause them to
want to consider staying there or
leaving
they're expert manipulators so they're
going to try to play their games to try
to divide but if the energy of the
synergist goes above the manipulator and
the manipulators no longer have any
voice they're going to find a different
place to go manipulate because they
won't stay here okay i just want you to
know this and if the manipulators leave
they will also attract other people that
will leave who think like them and they
will become best friends having dinners
together conversations together because
they
think they were more important than
these guys that can't help themselves
now here's the most unique thing about
the synergist you know what's the most
unique thing about the synergists the
last thing
they become heroes
even though that was never part of their
plan
they were never trying to become famous
they were never trying to become heroes
they can't help themselves
they so much believe in the cause of
your company your office your shop your
business whatever you they so much
believed in america they so much
believed in the principles that your
company the vision the mission that was
founded on they can't help themselves
but do this without wanting any credit
it's the most unique thing i remember
when i interviewed a chief disguise
officer the main chief disguise officer
of us of 28 years where she built uh the
the face
of george bush senior and sat in front
of him and showed that this is a mass
that he creates she created i said what
is the top quality of a great cia agent
he said they're charming they're
charismatic they're exciting they're
great salespeople great persuaders great
networkers there's only one thing
different about them i said what's that
when they save the free world from world
war three and they know they're the ones
that prevented somebody from starting
the next war they don't ever need the
credit and they don't ever take the
credit nobody finds out that they did it
they're behind closed doors right
that's the synergies except in this
situation
you can reveal to everybody who the
synergist is and build this person up so
if in your company you don't have a
synergist you got to start working on
being sometimes you have to be that
yourself before you find somebody else
who takes that role but by the way if
you're watching this yourself and you're
in a company in an office you want to be
the hero you want to go out there make
an impact you go speak the language of
the synergist and you build up the
people that came before you the prophet
the barbarian the builder explorer so
all of these things i just shared with
you is to give you an idea how you ought
to be thinking depending on the phase
you're at and what threats you may be
facing going into 2022 so having said
that if you got a lot of value from this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel two things i promise i'm
gonna have for you at the end as well
number one i got a one hour strategy
session video that i did for you you can
get that if you click on the link below
and subscribe to the newsletter we'll
give you that one hour strategy session
on how to think about going into 2022
and the other thing is everybody asked
about a business planning workshop and
since kobit is still going around and
people can't travel from all over the
world we decided to do a one-day
business planning workshop virtual
people can log in from anywhere in the
world that's going to be i believe on
december 20th if you haven't yet
reserved the seat for yourself and
gotten your tickets click on the link
below if you do have big plans for 2022
with a business plan you may want to
join us on that day on how to get deeper
on business plan this was 10 or 15
minutes that's going to be eight hours
of content having said that click on the
link below hopefully we'll see you there
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]